do you guys want to tell the podcast uh
fans what we're doing here okay today
we're in Ireland we are in Ireland we
are in Dublin Ireland just had a pretty
wild night
[Music]
all I say if you're gonna do a racist
stereotype you best do it right top of
the morning
Irish honor System please serve
yourselves put the money in the bucket
thank you uh I don't think the Irish
honest this is a thing man oh it's a big
it's an ancient Irish tradition know
your history book You Got Drugs you got
Irish people you got um I guess that's
the same thing a toast to Ireland a
razor glass
they're the Irish
anybody else out there uh drunk like me
and been drinking all day
Green Man bringing out the brown nectar
of the gods that was impressive because
I can say from experience he can't see
right now I don't know what I'm
doing right now what is this a podcast I
think we should talk about It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia oh yeah
don't you start because see Rob
Justice might actually come out on the
stage all right see
[Applause]
[Music]
I've never performed in front of that
many people before have you no that was
double the size of I think any of the
shows we've done uh well it sounded like
we did London the night before Royal
Albert Hall
last night we did
something like that I know it's a 9000
Cedar I don't know but and it was full
and a little shout out to the fans here
in Ireland who were uh amazing yeah yeah
they were great women they were they
were great too I thought that the
British would be a little bit more
reserved these people seem very drunk uh
how many guys are hammered
all right oh how many you actually have
to work tomorrow
it was pretty Rowdy in a good way yeah
yeah Rowdy in a good way made me feel
good in my heart and in my soul the
first time out of my ego it was the
first time that we ever this was very
near the heart deep inside the ego I
think it's located somewhere near the
heart that's right next to my heart yeah
it surrounds it first time we got a
safety briefing yeah
this is this is what's going to happen
here's the protocol guys how's your
I'm gonna be a bleary-eyed in this
in this particular podcast I'm not
sleeping well I'm not sleeping enough
and I am drinking a lot and today is
sort of our day of wrestling we're gonna
go to a wrexham game it will not be
restful for me and it will not be
restful it will be stressful
so when we get there we'll be restful at
all
no no it's it's very exciting
um it's very stressful at this point of
the season
um I I've I've talked about some live
shows but I haven't in our podcast I've
got double styes I got a stye here and a
style wait you got another one his buddy
no this one finally went away and this
one's just not going anywhere else I
kind of pulled up here and now it's like
it's going away but I have a feeling
but I talked to an optometrist and he
said well yes it's a clogged oil duct I
said okay well what could cause that he
goes well it could be caused by a
certain kind of particulate in the air a
lack of sleep extreme stress not
properly washing your eyes gotta wash
your eyes
yeah and and I was like well how do you
stop them he's like well reduce stress
get more sleep clean your eyes
and so I've done all the other things
but you can't reduce stress it's hard to
reduce stress and I with football I'm
blaming it solely on because you have no
control and I bet that I have more
control issues yeah yeah this is
challenging your ability right you can't
control the narrative on the phone
is together and then the rest oh boy yes
yeah that's I was nervous watching with
you yeah what was that what day was that
were they it was a draw or tie what'd
they say it was that did they say a draw
a tie is actually a match
like we're going to a tie tonight
wrap your head around that no no no no
it doesn't like it yeah no but
um okay so it was a draw it was a draw
and it was right down to the wire and
the opposing team had some good shots on
the goal there uh Edward boy very very
in and here's an interesting thing about
European uh football
uh they just the ref just sort of
arbitrarily adds time at the end of the
game to be like well you know what do
you think it's a draw right now four and
we're just gonna yeah four or five what
are you thinking
what are the boys I think they got a bit
in them let's let's give him six give
him six all right we'll give him six why
and then and then that time ends and
then it keeps going yeah it's for an
American Sports Fan that is maddening
like that you know what I mean the lack
of precision and it can just keep going
forever as long as there as long as an
offensive plays is continuing right so
it could be like extra time has elapsed
and even added time to the extra time
has elapsed if you're on the offense and
you keep making shots again they'll just
keep going but I feel like I've seen it
where the time elapses the ball changes
like it elapses it just elapses but then
the ball changes hands and they're like
and they're out there and they're like
tending to him and it takes four minutes
to do so the clock never stops it just
keeps going so the breath just goes
great you're we're waiting for the game
to pick up and yeah
so this this guy it took him about a
minute and a half to get up and uh so
we'll that's a minute and a half but
what is he doing
yeah that would make so much more sense
so everyone knows all right yeah I I
learned my lesson don't ask too many
questions just enjoy it yeah
yeah so now let's let's raise a toast
yeah I'm let's do it let's do it I'm
sorry you guys don't have oh wait wait a
minute now some of you oh
[Applause]
hey everybody oh Christ they're not good
looking let's get the lifestyle you all
have a buzzer in front of you um
[Music]
but uh how this game works
top four answers on the board name one
of rickety Cricket's injuries
these puzzles
show me no don't say show me
did you guys know that that was how
Danny pronounces the word or was
that just a happy accident that was a
happy accident yeah I mean that wasn't
the first time he's done it but
but yeah no that was
oh well thank you
some horror just uh
we have Mr Chase Utley
thank you
there are 31 million Americans who
identify as Irish
and I am one of them
Rob I'm also one of them what that
really proves is that the Irish can
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this feeling
I feel so strange inside
[Applause]
it is strange but appealing
[Music]
good
bye
[Applause]
[Music]
last night I I didn't sleep that well
but for literally the first time in my
life I was up all night because I was so
happy I couldn't go to sleep oh it was
weird because I've only ever had the
anxious thing and last night I was just
like I don't want this date yeah in
front of that many people I just
couldn't sleep I was just going over in
my head how great it was and it was like
the most that's why I couldn't sleep
last night or for the last week yeah so
what'd you do about it I just laid there
and like appreciated it just soaked it
up too well I have had so many nights
where I'm like oh my God I'm so anxious
like leading up to these shows you know
there's a lot of like anxiety about
wanting it to go well and having been a
sunny fan for so long the last thing I
want to do in the world is like
disappoint other Sunny fans so uh I was
really nervous and I had nights where I
stayed up thinking about like oh did I
pick all the right clips and that but
last night truly I was just like like
living it again in my head like over and
it was it was just like so I mean you
could just feel their love constantly
even when they're being quiet you could
feel the love of I've never experienced
anything like that in my life you guys
have presumably like been in front of
lots of Sunny fans before and feeling
that kind of Rush you've talked about
like Comic-Con before and like feeling
that energy I've never had that before
but they are so locked in it's crazy
it's a little I find it a little
intimidating when we're just talking
because you know when we have a funny
clip to play or when we're doing like uh
you know like the family fight game
which has been going over well or when
I'm getting to sing songs which have
like a beginning middle and end and
everyone knows what they are like that's
very comfortable when we're just
chatting I'm like ah how do I see that
in you I see you very specifically
wanting to like keep things moving
forward I see you turn like man yeah
I get it like I get it well you're
you're I'm just wanting to entertain I
just want to entertain so I'm like is
this I think it's good I think people
want to hear us like slow down you stop
down more than I think we ever have
maybe in a live show last night to talk
about uh because you're you picked
Charlie Clips to talk about Charlie and
and in that moment and you know I I I
just I was like I think people do want
to hear this I've been asked to pick my
favorite clips of Mr Charlie Day
[Applause]
this is such an honor for me
um I'm gonna try not to get too
emotional but I will talk a little bit
about Charlie
um and I think I've mentioned this on
the podcast but I'm gonna I'm gonna tell
the story again I I met Charlie Day on
an airplane
we we were both testing a screen test is
when you're auditioning for a role and
you're really close it's usually down to
like three or four or maybe sometimes
two other people and we were living in
New York City at the time and they put
actors on planes they they fly them out
to LA
you then audition and you get to see who
gets the part for whatever reason they
sat us next to each other you were going
for the same part we're going for the
same part they sat you next well you
could always spot the actor actually
like in the in the lobby because he's
the only other person like waiting for
the flight like this
no you do
it
so I spied you I knew I knew we were out
yes so immediately we know okay that's
that's the guy
and I'm sitting with him and I'm
thinking I'm gonna ice this
out I got this guy
I'm a tad competitive and I thought well
all right I got this job so somewhere
where we get out of JFK and uh somewhere
over
somebody just would oh okay
yeah
uh one of our most Irish presidents
other than Biden
you're goddamn right
yeah go ahead sorry
Irish JFK Irish Catholic yeah yeah we
shot him
wow
too many guns two too many guns
he's not wrong that's just those are
just facts yeah yeah
anyway go on about me
so somewhere over Ohio and for those of
you who don't uh aren't familiar with
the contiguous United States it's like a
state and a half over from New York I
realized I'm not going to get this job
this is one of the funniest people I've
ever met in my entire life and I am
I am wasting the next four hours
of a plane ride in the next three days
of my life so it was a comedy that you
were going yeah it was a comedy
I know yeah it's like yeah you're
good luck to almost anybody in the world
truly
[Applause]
well yes uh neither
neither one of us got the job because
the whole thing fell apart they canceled
the show
they said now this is this is not
working but what was birthed from that
was a friendship
and from that point forward we would
check in with each other and um and we
would always talk about how
how everything that he was working on
and all the jobs he was getting which
were plentiful
um still weren't creatively fulfilling
he didn't have any control or power over
what was happening I wasn't working at
all
um but I I realized that wow there are
some really talented people out there
and if I could take and I can't do what
he can do but I can do something else
and if I could take what I could do and
and work with him and work with people
like him and hitch my wagon to his star
then I would be along for the ride
I'm dead serious and that's what's been
happening ever since
I could I could honestly say the same
exact thing about Glenn but this isn't
about Glenn for once
for once
the whole show is so big and
entertaining and we are doing a bunch of
stuff I think it's I think we should
stop down every once in a while and just
like get in you know what I mean like
because then it's then it's because
otherwise it's just you know yeah it's
like I'm not saying I'm imposed to it
I'm saying that's the only time that I
feel a little bit like oh what's
happening yeah you know the minutes seem
to take hours yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
drag on yeah I think you can see how
people can get up by that
experience um and you hear that same
story over and over again of people in
our business getting to perform it from
large groups of people feeling the
adulation or love coming from the crowd
up into the stage and I think what
happens is people get addicted to it and
they think that all that external
validation is eventually going to make
them happy which it will and but but I
think that the lesson that generally is
learned I think is still the wrong
lesson which is you shouldn't seek that
kind of validation because it'll never
bring you happiness I think that there's
some truth to that but I also believe
that there's a version of that
experience last night that we actually
did go through where you're not you're
not making it about yourself but we are
also sharing in the experience of the 9
000 people and it's all about the
community of people that love this one
thing I think but that's real that's
that's the difference that's the
difference that's the difference right
there though right it's how you process
that information right it's how you how
you interpret that how you what you what
your takeaway is right because if your
takeaway is like I'm badass
then you know that's that's probably not
great but if your takeaway is like
wow I may I I think we've made I think
we've done something that's like made a
lot of people that was so awesome about
the credit well all the crowds but
especially last night where
um I was thinking like gosh it's so
great for each other what a good time
they're giving each other right like
we're doing a percentage of it which is
like singing dancing telling jokes but
they were chanting breaking into so like
just song which if I was a fan just
going to a show I'd be like
you want to be with the excited crowd
you know my favorite moment was we
played a clip of uh Mac and Dennis uh
moved to the suburbs and uh it was one
thank you so much with a lemon in it
lovely oh yes thank you very good
appreciate it thank you and it was that
moment where uh uh Dennis says news
flash and the crowd
spontaneously all joined in and said it
at the same time
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
and I think that the the takeaway that I
have from it which I think is a thing
you get to keep and and you don't have
to keep chasing is that you feel like
less alone and I think that's like what
everybody felt in the crowd was like
they've seen all those clips a million
times it's not that they're getting the
jokes new it's that they're sitting next
to people and they're laughing with
people and they feel like they have a
family and that they're and and I know
you guys you did a lot of meet and
greets and I'm sure you heard it over
and over and over again uh people saying
I was going through a really dark time I
had like I felt really sad and you guys
lifted me up and that is just giving
them the feeling that there's somebody
with them you know and I think that was
the thing they loved last night was
watching those clips with other Sunny
fans and and you gotten watching you
guys watch it too and knowing that
you're part of that family with them
that there's not a separation between
them and you I think that's I think
that's 100 spot on and I think that is
what makes it so special because the way
they feel about the show is how I feel
about the show you know what I mean it's
like do something you feel like is so uh
we're doing something that's so
authentic to our experience our life
experience our sense of humor our you
know need to satirize society whatever
it is you know and
you know as we've spoken about many
times we've we it was all done
essentially in a very pure way just like
okay we can't really if you can't really
know what an audience is going to
respond to so all we can really do is
make something that's gonna that you
think is funny that you think is funny
that I think is funny and that we think
is funny so then to do that and and then
see how many people actually feel the
same way you do you know it that it's
like you said it it it makes you feel
like you're you're part of something and
it is the biggest Shame about like
comedy movie movies in particular not
being in theaters enough oh I know to
get in there with a crowd and like oh
and experience for people I mean I I you
remember watching I'm sure you guys went
and saw like Borat in the theater that
was the premiere and sat in the front
row and and still laughed my ass
off to stare
just stare up and have that giant naked
guy you know like the two of them like
wrestling
I mean that that's one of the greatest
theatrical experiences of my entire life
was watching that movie watching South
Park the South Park movie uh with an
audience in a theater and soon
watching Fool's Paradise oh yeah buddy
but we just love what we're
doing and like I'm not gonna do anything
of it I'm not gonna have a blast doing
it like being here tonight yeah
I do think it is it is a separation
between pride and ego right you can be
proud of your work without the takeaway
without like building up your own ego
too much or making it too much about
that I think you can separate those
things in the same way that there is a
difference between you know arrogance
and confidence it's like it's it's good
to be confident it's not good to be
arrogant that being said I did enjoy
people chanting my name
before we watch this clip actually this
is just like a little backstory of of
this one because I wrote this episode
and
ah thanks guys yeah you can you can you
can let the ego build up a little bit
yeah no listen I mean it's an essential
part of the psyche right is is the ego
it can't you don't want it to be nothing
gotta have a balance you know what I
mean gotta have a balance but yeah I
don't know I mean that that experience
of of being with that many people that
all kind of feel the same way about
something is is just a yeah it's a
beautiful beautiful thing
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Glenn you know what we're doing
today
we're getting salty man oh so much salt
because we have a brand new sponsor yeah
element spelled
l-m-n-t is a great way to replenish your
electrolytes their drink mixes come with
everything you need and nothing that you
don't so we're talking no sugar no but
plenty of the salt the good salt you
know so much salt you might be like no
that's too much but it isn't you'd be
wrong you stupid idiot it's the right
amount of salt that was salty I told you
yeah element can help you eliminate
headaches muscle cramps fatigue
sleeplessness and other common symptoms
of electrolyte deficiency which is
namely a sodium deficiency those
hangovers you know you get yourself a
good quality Ireland hangover look out
again yeah that's why you gotta have
your element yeah that's not help me man
right now elements is offering my
listeners a free sample pack with any
purchase that's eight single serving
packets free with any element order this
is a great way to try all eight flavors
and share elements
with a salty friend yeah get yours at
drinkelement.com Sunny
the deal is only available through our
link you must go to d r i n k l m n
t.com slash Sunny is the only way to get
the stuff it offers no questions asked
refunds right so if you want your money
back try it you know try it it's totally
risk-free if you don't like it share it
with a salty friend and they will give
and they will give you your money back
no questions asked your friend has to
give money you have nothing to lose here
foreign
I can't believe it's been over a month
since we've been in the UK and Ireland
that was it was amazing yeah well it's
been over a month for you guys but I was
right because you were still there you
were there she stayed out there a second
longer than us what else did you do over
there well I just booked like a bunch of
different tours on Viator okay I'm gonna
stop you right there tell me more about
this Viator what is it it's a place that
I could book uh over 300 000 different
travel experiences and over 190
countries they offer everything from
simple tours to Extreme Adventures so
like I hit up Stonehenge and then also
the Harry Potter Muggles tour oh you did
nerd stuff I figured that
um I would go on Viator and they not
only have really cool experiences but
also uh they have like millions of real
traveler reviews and as a writer I
really I live for good reviews oh yeah
yeah okay so maybe next time we go uh on
a tour with the show we also do a bunch
of reviews now hold on a second here
because I'm just I'm leaving this review
here um are you doing a quick review I'm
gonna do a review here
um the Muggle tour that mag was
referring to muggle tour does not
compare to Sunny tour okay again you're
being such a Death Eater right now okay
so you can download the Viator app now
and use the code viator10 for 10 off
your first booking one app over 300 000
experiences that you'll remember do more
with Viator that's
v-i-a-t-o-r and use the code Viator 10
for 10 off
thank you
well I love what you were bringing up
after the Royal Albert Hall shows the
second one in particular you mentioned
to Charlie on the bus back that um you
could really see him soaking up a moment
of playing the songs and like feeling
like holy I'm in such a I'm in a
hundred and uh 150 year old venue
um where I watched it happen yeah and
and I am playing these songs that I
wrote and people are singing along they
know all the words and we got to see you
just have yeah it's such a trip for me
to get to do that you know to really
kind of just play Rockstar for 15-20
minutes at the end of the show
and to play music and have people sing
along I think that's why I enjoyed it so
much you know because I like that that
first night as you know you got it there
you did the songs they sounded amazing
but you were doing your thing you were
putting on a show you know as what
you're supposed to do try to make sure
you hit the right notes yeah yeah well
there's that to the technical side right
because it's not like you play all the
time and certainly not in front of an
audience but um but then the second
night yeah it was like
okay wait a minute let me actually I'm
at Royal Albert Hall like
historic venue like I can you know you I
could just see I literally watched you
in that moment I don't know you you like
transformed into like you really owned
it
there is a spider spider spider
deep in my soul
[Applause]
you just can't let go
he's hanging around
it's got a mean bite
now he's ready to
fight
and stand up for what he knows
[Music]
I just wanna tell you all go
yourself
[Music]
my work is on
[Applause]
you know I had him I'm middle of one of
the songs I don't remember which one it
was and I looked up and I saw the
monitor that's projecting I saw you
doing I shout out to the crowd I was
like oh right so then I don't know
just like an actor I was like all right
where's the camera let me try to like
make sure I have my hat a little more
towards the camera so it's a little more
entertaining for someone I'm not just
like looking down at the keys although I
need to a little bit
um that was a great addition by the way
to this uh because you know we we are
putting on these live shows we've never
done I've certainly never planned like a
whole stage show before and so we were
learning things in the Philly shows we
didn't have uh big screens with you guys
close up project and I think it changed
the whole it made it feel so much more
intimate they could see your faces your
reactions to things you enjoying the
stuff and that in particular you could
see you spitting on the crowd which they
love I forgot to spit last night you
gotta remember to spit on them
ending a show with telling the audience
to go themselves it's amazing well
that's not really what we're doing right
we're really what we're doing is we're
all collectively saying go
yourselves to anyone who doesn't get it
the people who don't get Sunny blue
don't get it that's really what it is
yeah and that's the joy of it that's the
jam that's the joy of it because we all
collectively know they're wrong
yeah exactly
[Applause]
we're gonna do one more of these
and then we might do some throughout the
summer here and there back in the States
yeah it's really fun yeah it's really
we're just gonna we can't because just
because of our schedules we can't do
like a a full tour where we just go for
like a month or two months unfortunately
sadly so we just have we're basically we
would want to do that even if your
schedules I wasn't gonna say that cut
that I was I was I was you're right
that's why we're not doing it but it's
just about my kids
yeah I just miss my kids and I'll miss
your kids I'm sorry those are the
reasons what's your excuse oh I'm
tired I I don't have kids I just
we do this and then by the end of it I'm
like we are your kids yeah sort of Glenn
calls me a podcast Mommy because uh yeah
is that in the elevator at the hotel the
other after the show and Charlie and
Glenn and I were in the elevator and
we're like what room are you in and
Glenn goes I haven't got any idea no
idea that's the thing no idea you know
like when you do these tours and like
the guy who's running it like you know
he he handles like Bruno Mars and stuff
right yeah you're whisked into a hotel
at 3am there they hand you the room key
they basically walk you up there if you
don't pay a little bit of attention
you'll be like wait what wait what
country am I in and what
I'm truly intoxicated
we have an incredible tour management
team and they are used to doing rock
stars and so rockstars tend to be
younger and a little bit less
responsible yes 46 year old men
so producers of a television series so
we we're not used to being handled the
way that we're being handled right now
no no nor do we like it because we're
like hey man like uh let me hold my own
passport
check your passports and they're like we
got it covered and you're like this is
so uncomfortable okay but if you can let
it go it is it's a beautiful thing no
it's fun I don't I don't ever I I don't
think I ever want to get used to it
because I think because it it could be
one of those things where you
you know you're you're in your house by
yourself and you're like tissue
and no one's answering because you're in
your giant mansion
it's fun it's fun it's like we get to
play rock and roll stars for a week you
know what I mean like it's all sort of
my my favorite part it's all the best
parts we're not doing yeah wait what are
the best parts the drugs and the banging
Rockstar drugs
we're not doing the sex we're not doing
the drugs and we're actually not even
really doing the rock and roll a little
tiny bit of it you know
this is the best crowd we've had
for any of these oh my God absolutely
there are so many people here
anybody else Hanging On by a thread
I sent a video
of this room to my friends from Philly
there's 15 almost 15 of them on the
chain and they all said one of them said
please tell uh Meg I said hello without
it being too creepy then everybody said
oh hi Meg Jesus Christ Meg flame Emoji
what is this oh my gosh Philly that's
like that but from what based on what I
just filmed a video like this I ended
with you and you just went like that and
you're hit your family friends uh after
the Philly shows we got we got together
they they were very nice to me very
sweet we talked about getting tattoos
together it was I was pretty drunk and
we were talking about getting some
tattoos together classic uh yeah it was
classic late night drunk conversation we
should get tattoos like right now it was
like Sunday night at two in the morning
and I was like you were close I was real
I would have gone I probably you would
have done it after the Phillies show
yeah after the fellowship what would the
tattoo would have been uh like did you
have it did you did you know what you
wanted to get you should get a sunny
related tattoo
I've always felt like I should get two
tattoos related to Comedy one should be
something related to Sunny maybe just
bad new tattooed somewhere on my body
and then I'll draw it if you wanted yeah
I might do it bad news are cool it's a
cool thing and then the other one is I'd
like to get an onion related tattoo
because I I started on the onion that
was like one of my first big jobs and
I've always wanted to get the onion logo
maybe so I want to put like Semper Fi on
my shoulder you know what I mean so I
can just be like except for five baby
um just cooler it's just cooler than we
could do that on the Pod maybe sometime
you could write bad news and I could get
it tattooed sure you got it I don't
think I have to prove my Sunny fandom
anymore but no do you have any tattoos I
do I have two tattoos yeah yeah tats
you're all tatted up I got two I want
more I was reading an article about uh
your body is always trying to fight your
tattoo it sees it as an infection really
and it's uh what yeah and they're not
sure why the skin doesn't just dump it
out like what why it stays oh that's
weird yeah well I can't get rid of it I
mean they do they do they can't fade and
like all articles I picked up very
little details that I can actually
regurgitate into an interesting
conversation
a few headlines a few things enough to
just get you got I was talking oh has
time to read an entire article no I
probably read the whole thing I remember
very little your brain rejects that like
this body rejects tattoos it just like
pushes out the information slowly it's
like what are we gonna do with this
Charlie well ain't gonna help us Rob's
getting his tattoos removed how's that
going good but she's keeping Shamrock
I made a Rob show with shamrock tattoo
to the audience last night I was
objectified again I mean I was I course
into it yeah yeah by the audience though
well and I didn't I didn't force you I
just there was an implication that
something would go wrong it didn't if
you didn't get food
the implication is that it's real it's a
real thing yeah that's why it's funny
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there's only one way to show it
down go the fans
all right he's got to take his pants off
for it
it's the only way
here we go
there's the Chevron
were you actually like uh slightly
mortified well you're was it what was
what you you it was like I was like are
your pants
no no I was just afraid that my dentist
oh you're afraid yeah because you don't
yeah that is definitely make sure
honestly I got so nervous for a split
second I looked at the wrong leg I
forgot which legs then I was like wait
where is it and then I just was like I
just don't want my dick it's hard to
know these days when it's appropriate to
take your dick out you know what I mean
we never know anymore we never know
we're like when can I you know you're
always think that every room I walk into
I'm like can I take my dick out in this
room and then I'm like no I think
that I would have got the best there
because that's not a power move it's the
I would have been I would have been the
victim yeah if my dick were to fall out
on stage while the audience was like
take it out and I was like I don't know
yeah you're the victim in that City yeah
that's like your Fame moment where you
were like I guess you know
this is what you want
to get your to get your shot
did you get your shot oh no Meg did a
secret Santa where she said hey pick
three clips and you know you gave me
Glenn and Rob got me and then Glenn got
robbed and then uh on the next show
you'll do Danny
um here's what I'm curious about I don't
know I didn't know that yeah if um I was
wondering about that I was like wait
yeah oh nice good
um if uh we'll start with you Rob Rob if
you had to pick your own Clips your own
three Clips which scenes would you would
you have picked
oh wow
it's a little harder because
you know when people ask us about
Charlie mcdennis and how much fun it was
to make because it seems like it was so
fun because the people loved the episode
it was actually miserable it was because
your experience of Performing something
isn't always necessarily
how the way that it winds up and the way
that it's perceived by other people is
really got little to do with like the
performance that you gave the Revenant
was an amazing movie you think Leonardo
DiCaprio had a good time filming it
no he didn't we're screaming the entire
episode right so to like we're out of 10
the whole time like it's exhausting yeah
to think about like what I would pick
out for myself it would be things that I
had the most fun making I think you know
right which is not really the the the
assignment that's fine you can do that
how about the dance yeah I mean
something like that the fat dance or the
fit dance the fat dancer fit dance I
would say just the well because the fat
dance funny too but both both because
that you know what yes I think those are
top those are tied for one because uh
because they represented putting in
months and months yeah hard work paying
off work together and then it winds up
paying off for a brief second and to me
that's what's fun about it that even the
dance itself which was very long it was
only four minutes and it took me six
months to learn how to do that and to
get my body in the shape yeah and the
and the fat the fat is just just dancing
across the stage for four seconds I can
see it when he says it runs through my
mind it's the look on his face and this
the fact that he's going sideways the
the Michael Jackson kind of moment at
the end when you throw your shirt back
there's that one too
that little I I've picked one is that
Glenn picked for you which was the um
I've had an orgasm
I'll put my thumb through here yeah yeah
yeah yeah
I got Mr Rob mcelhenney now
you guys do know how to pronounce his
last name right
[Applause]
down now that's gonna be stuck in our
heads for the rest of our lives if you
want to play that video no no no no do
not do not oh for the love of God that's
funny because I just met Ryan a couple
years ago and he spent about 150 000
pounds making a video for my birthday
and what did you guys do
uh we made you millions and millions of
dollars yeah sorry yeah yeah we made you
we made you famous We Made You full stop
We Made You
Ryan Reynolds is a total Schmitty but
Ryan Reynolds at schmitting he's
schmitting us yeah he is
um
but uh not only did we make you Rob
but you made us
uh it's true and if it were not for you
uh this show would not exist
and
it wouldn't be even a fraction as funny
as as it is without you my friends
you're a phenomenal writer you're a
phenomenal actor
you're a phenomenal phenomenal friend
and I want to watch some clips of you
doing some funny yeah
Glenn I'm very I'm very curious what you
picked okay well there'll be so many I
know that so I know that like I know
that people enjoy watching my character
get angry but I enjoy
I I enjoy your character getting angry
because it doesn't like you it go it
when it comes on it's fast and it is
beyond anything I can it's fast and it's
Furious so so I wanted to see uh some of
my favorite moments of you getting
Furious
okay that's for all the clap roll the
tape hey I'm Matt welcome to Paddy's
Club
signature blending trip Caribbean
parents people say it's better than an
ordinance not that he's never had one
come on dude I'm Australia I'll stick my
goddamn stuff through your eye
one of the corners does the Paddy's Pub
and thick lines
Through Your Eyes
men's women's bathroom thing is
Antiquated maybe your answer
now
now hold on
some through the eye
all right the the Strangling your wife
that's funny
you're bursts of anger were just so so
funny to me like any time you go into
these bursts of anger and then
immediately like calm down like that
shit's always really funny but then
there were some of like uh the clips
that you showed of Charlie and honestly
I mean I was loving what you were doing
but I was also noticing those scenes I
couldn't help but notice I'm like oh
those are so great for Rob too like
I felt like I didn't necessarily pick
the best ones but uh but that's good
it's a testament to like I think they're
just there are a lot I was choosing as I
explained like I was choosing ones very
carefully for specific reasons that it
wasn't just what made me laugh no no it
was it was ones where where I wanted to
point out to the audience what makes
Charlie so special yeah
you know I had a really tough job my job
was to pick clips for Charlie again look
how do you do that how do you do that so
I had to whittle it down and my very
first pick
is from an episode called underage
drinking
a national concern
now maybe I actually I might set this up
so this was early in the show and I
remember
um I had a very strong take on this
episode and I especially early on I was
able to like I just wrote this very
quickly I had an idea a pitch for the
episode I wrote it very very quickly and
the first draft I got to the guys and
they were like oh okay this looks good
we could probably
shoot this then of course we did our
pass through it and it got even better
but then what you're about to see
um
in this scene and in this little
monologue Charlie
um ad-libs something that was not in the
script and it became an iconic line in
the history of the show let's watch that
what's going on
Tammy Trey's ex-girlfriend this is
classic Tammy
Trey broke up with Tammy because Marine
canalin said that she saw Tanya flirting
with a Walt Timmy at a party but she was
only doing it to make Trey jealous
because you know she thought that Trey
secretly liked Aaron Henry betrayed him
what is happening
Trey's ex-girlfriend this is classic
Tammy Trey broke up with taking you know
what Charlie you got to stop honestly
okay
so the reason I led with this was not
because it's the funniest thing that
Charlie's ever done because again that's
it's impossible it's impossible it's
because he took something and elevated
it exponentially further than any of us
could could have imagined by just saying
the words classic Tammy
that's classic Tammy
I actually that wasn't in the script no
calling her that's classic Tammy no and
and another reason why I chose that is
because I know you guys would probably
not even remember it I don't even know I
don't remember no
[Music]
our show today is brought to you by
rocket money get out of here rocking
money yeah rocket money is a personal
finance app that finds and cancels your
unwanted subscriptions monitors are
spending and helps you lower your bills
all in one place that's right we saved
this one for when Glenn is with us
because uh you're You're such you're
such an Enthusiast hello man I love you
love the applications the more the
better I I every anytime I have to
download a new app
hey it's exciting I love it but I bet
you do uh feel good about them when they
save you money on unwanted subscriptions
right okay all sarcasm aside I do love
saving money I love money is great I
like money yeah especially when the
average American thinks they spend
eighty dollars a month on subscriptions
but in reality they actually spend
closer to two hundred dollars and it's a
lot of money to be off uh you know
perception wise to think you're only
spending like 60 to 70 and be spending
200. that's a big gap that's a big hit
yeah but that's a job for a robot to be
tracking is where your money is going
not not for people it's like we just let
rocket money do that for us just stop
throwing money away right that's the
main takeaway here you know cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com
Sunny the slash Sunny part is important
that's rocketmoney.com Sunny that's
rocketmoney.com sunny I wanna rocket
some money to my pocket yeah you want a
pocket pocket full of money
[Music]
I had an idea Charlie for an rcg
business venture oh my God another one
with the abundance of time that we have
yeah okay yeah what do you got okay so
check this out
um
we have all these Sunny sets you know we
built over the years and what do we do
with them in the in the off season we
put them in storage yeah we keep them in
storage exactly we keep them locked away
where no one can enjoy them and you know
can't make money off them but what if
what if okay what if
we let people pay
to come and take pictures on on our sets
yeah okay okay but slow down you got to
think about the overhead right we'd have
to hire a staff we got to get a bunch of
Pas kind of like getting people in and
out of these these sets let's see that's
the easy part okay we just use zip
recruiter oh right because whether
you're starting a new business uh or
you're growing one uh if you want it to
be successful you need the most talented
people on your team that's where
ZipRecruiter comes in okay and right now
you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
Sunny exactly ziprecruiters powerful
matching technology finds highly
qualified candidates for a wide range of
of roles and tell me about these
candidates well if we happen to see some
candidates that we really like we can
personally invite them to apply right
let's zip recruiter fill all your rolls
right four out of five employers uh who
post on ZipRecruiter they get a quality
candidate within the first day see for
yourself go to this exclusive web
address to try ZipRecruiter for free
ziprecruiter.com
slash sunny again that
ziprecruiter.com Sunny ZipRecruiter the
smartest way to hire
I want to hear your guys top one let's
just do one what's your top moment of
yourself in the show either the one you
had the most fun filming or just the one
that you're like well I'm pretty
proud of that moment hmm
like some some of my favorite ones
weirdly are like out of character for
what I normally am but like
uh uh I I like that I've grown quite
weary speech like that
flowers for Charlie yeah
yeah Pepe Sylvia and honestly the the
Ryan Gosling
Ryan Gosling playing you how ridiculous
I don't know why those are the ones I
had the most fun you know what's funny
is I it you actually it much like it's
usually me that does this but as I
recall like when we went to shoot that
you were doing it and you were like this
is this is not this is too big this I
was oh that's funny yeah and then and I
was the one I was the one who was like
no no go further oh great go further
with it and the more you go and you're
like all right I'll do one that's like
insane and then you did it and it was so
funny and you felt it too and we're like
all right this is ridiculous it makes no
sense it's just funny it's just
funny yeah it's one of the rare
instances in which like you had you were
kind of backing away from something and
I was like no no no no go go go go go
there's really no reason to be like
talking like that but it's just funny
it's just well you had the wires
sticking out your mouth I was like yes I
can't I like I can't talk right is that
the one you had the thing too the it was
like a gas mask that you feel yeah wow
what about you for you honestly have no
I I I'm not this is they were that was
tough for me to pick because there's so
many good dentist moments the one and
only Mr Glenn Howerton I got to pick
your Clips buddy
pretty excited about this
I got a little pizza paper here to to
just to set them up Charlie's my biggest
fan so
[Music]
so much you're acting
as uh you're breaking now you don't
always break in a scene
but this is uh one of Dennis's finest
scenes and uh when Glenn's finest
moments this was our last day of filming
this season this is Dennis uh needing
his tools
what's up
duct tape zip ties tools I have I have
to have my tools why do you keep all the
in your car
finish it you know I'd like to bind
stuff I like Divine I like the beam
what's all that stuff you're grabbing
dude
[Laughter]
one of my favorites though is you saying
idiots and savages
the pitch that your voice goes into
um is so funny it gets like so high
pitched idiots it's not fun what they
were doing wasn't funny coming up
Christ damn man down now that's the
first time we went we went we were like
what happens if we take that thing that
we're that gear that we're finding and
like I'm really doing what you did for
me with the braces thinking that one was
like go even just just the angrier you
get the more incense the more insane you
feel about this the better and what a
pick tools I want to pick tools yeah
yes it is it is funny because there are
certain things that like other people
think are like you know super super
funny like the implication scene which I
think is
well so I think so I I this is the two
of you together in that scene you guys
are like a perverse Laurel and Hardy
so it's not that I just I like my
performance in that scene but to me the
thing that makes that scene so funny is
what you guys wrote and your reaction to
What not that's just for me that's just
for me now I'm not saying I don't I do
like my performance in it but and I
think my performance is good but I don't
think it's my best work I think it's
good but I think the best thing about
that scene is that the actual speech
itself and honest for me your reactions
to it but that it's so funny that you're
getting so irritated with him that he's
saying and you're like you're not
understanding it and the more irritated
you become with him not understanding it
the funnier yeah yeah you know it's
certainly misunderstanding me another
one of my favorites and it's a rant but
it's a different gear also because it's
quieter is I will put you in a box when
you do that
that's a good one A Tiny Box because
because it's a weird
proud to me the other day maybe
able to watch
I do and uh and I watch it again it's
great honestly anytime I can
make Caitlyn break
I will shove you into a box
you on display
rotting Fish Furniture
a glass box
but it's just like what like I don't
know you know me because you know
Caitlyn's like she's a tough one to
Break like we break all the time Caitlyn
doesn't break that off and Danny doesn't
break that often but Caitlin Danny
started breaking more have you noticed
a lot I think yeah I don't know and by
breaking we mean laughing not breaking
he's perfectly fine nothing's happening
to Danny it's an industry term he's
tough to break breaking means uh
laughing in the scene but um yeah anyway
I think most people know it but you guys
we've done it yeah we've got to wrap it
up because we got to get over to another
country we've got to get to Wales today
going to Wales and then back to Dublin
and here come the stars and they've
added six minutes to the clocks
and six more stats foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Bob
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
and it feels like it's supposed to feel
[Music]
God knows to see
let's make the best
[Music]
for me
foreign
[Music]